it's wednesday evening at bakken the
world's largest heavy metal festival the
opening act is a band made up of local
firefighters just like every year 120
bands are scheduled to play during the
four-day festival including top acts
like rammstein Alice Cooper and
Motorhead the crowd is estimated at
80,000 including many music fans from
other countries buqun has achieved cult
status among many metal fans the [ __ ]
open air festival takes place every
August in northern Germany suddenly this
otherwise quiet village is taken over by
metal fans
Marcus aye maalik the atmosphere is
unique all these people have the same
interests and they all get along fine
it's great that the people are so
laid-back despite the dense crowds the
atmosphere is great everybody's cool you
can hang out wherever you want I don't
have a percent in smoking I'm lovely
movie the metallicity metal isn't just
music it's also a kind of culture it
brings together people from all over the
world you get that here the sixth
woodland here Tomas Jensen is the Bakken
festivals co-founder he and a group of
friends organized the first festival
back in nineteen ninety eight hundred
people turned out this year its 80,000
jumper from clan I before we started out
organizing small rock music parties then
we decided to hold an open air festival
I'm talk before we had no idea what we
were doing in the early 90s we couldn't
have imagined it would turn into
something of this magnitude tens of
thousands of music fans have pitched
their tents at the campground near by
it's been raining so the place is now a
sea of mud but that doesn't bother real
metal fans lots of people showed up even
before the festival actually began this
group from tri blog has been here for
several days already
I'm Fiona and it's basically just a huge
party zone and you can camp here but
people don't come here to camp or sleep
because of the noise out day and night
you know him dr. more civilized
accommodations are available on board
the MS [ __ ] a hotel ship that's docked
about four kilometers away on the Kiel
Canal four nights on board plus festival
tickets will cost you 749 euros machado
kruger who owns a travel agency came up
with the idea for a floating metal hotel
ya homusal feel this is the 24th bakken
festival some of the people who started
coming to the festival way back when are
a little older now and they expect more
comfort for lunch bushes and augustin
that includes Inga in dr ghulam who've
traveled here from southern germany
they've been attending metal festivals
for nearly two decades they're both over
40 now and they don't feel like sleeping
in the mud at some camp ground anymore
so the MS Bakken is the perfect
alternative
for biomedical shows a few years ago I'd
have said what the heck let's bring a
tent but nowadays we expect more out of
life after the show you can have a
shower climb into bed and feel great oh
just get food it's bakken open-air day
two at the campsite people are just
crawling out of their sleeping bags
while the guests on board the MS [ __ ]
are enjoying a breakfast buffet
but these metal fans regardless of
whether they've spent the night in a
tent or on board a hotel ship all have
one thing in common they love heavy
metal